we have taken a long journey through
this topic so far we've done a lot of
involved algebra we are going to make an
exciting discovery today so to help you
get the context for that I just want us
to remember this ok this is what some of
the things I loved about love that
mathematics but is kind of um like is is
frustrating when you don't appreciate
like why it is the way it is I love that
now you guys can look at those three
lines one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven symbols that's
like what it's like less than a tenth of
a tweet okay you can look at those ten
symbols and they are laden with me now
in fact I heard of like images start to
pop into your head as you look at each
one you understand what is being
referred to here right we've been
exploring is this particular ratio
namely exeter city right and we said why
just like about whether you think about
them ferguson directories and then you
explore these you get different shapes
the shapes that you get in order are the
circle
when you increase you get the eyelids
right it stretches out and then if you
stretch far enough you hit a set point
that ratio hits one to one right you
don't get a closed shape anymore with
with a center and with two foci instead
you get a round earlier shape and we
were the fighter plane in lockers and
penetrates even faster I said this leads
to the obvious question right of what
happens what does this mean we saw that
it would present some problems for us
why we were looking at where I owe you
get like B squared B if you didn't know
what's that supposed to be okay special
ed to be is meant to be a leg complex
numbers are not going to seem very happy
on that Cartesian plane okay so what we
are going to do is we are going to grab
the bull by the horns and we're just
going to perform okay now the other is a
little bit involved sometimes borrow a
goat and also pictures and hopefully
that will help us make some sense okay
so let's begin by picking some values we
can explore this way of a concrete
example just like we did before when we
discovered the ellipse so for example
i'm going to pick a focus at know
40 symmetrix oriented this way and just
for the sake of simplicity let's choose
the smallest integer that is satisfying
this is graded one now you and see what
pops out now without a variable point
Coupee all I need to say is that the
relationship the algebraic relationship
who governs all of these is simply as PS
equals a pity adds all it is and that's
why PS OPD is that ratio okay I require
knowledge of two points and also
knowledge on perpendicular distance okay
and it's an algebra is going to involve
an equation is going to jump out of it
takes kind of like four or five or six
lines but it's just algebra so would you
do me a better and start off you've got
your two point distance for me on right
here's the perpendicular distance for me
I can go to square collect like terms
and see what emerges I'll give you a few
minutes I hope you get there there are I
think there are maybe 33 in between your
lines probably ish in between here for
after you collect some lanterns and so
on but this should be what emerges out
it should be what you get
people yeah I know what the eccentricity
is right light it's a value I've got a
particular ratio in like dying you okay
now let's have a look at this it is both
immediately familiar but also kind of
unsettlingly different right because it
looks almost identical to an ellipse it
says it ain't right what would make this
an ellipse if there was a plus here that
would be an ellipse okay great right but
it's not and like when you go through
this I remember the first time I did
this I thought about doing something
wrong but you know when you get assigned
role I mean you're like did I take it
across its not changed possible matters
but you've done it right this is it this
is what you should end up with I'm
funded in this familiar a squared B
squared 14 because due to the fact that
there's this a different stretching in
different horizontal horizontal and
vertical stretching again there's no
number of you that makes sense is like
the radius for a circle or any other
kind of common measure you've just got
this kind of proportionality two more
shape now some of you will have severe
like you recognize this formula oh I
know what that looks like okay but i'm
really going to very consciously avoid
that because it's not a given what this
is at all and I want us to work through
like how do I go from this to an actual
picture because that's where I was
trying to end up so my first suggestion
is well you've got this equation what's
the most important like geometric fact
that you can get out of an equation when
you're trying to graph it
probably the easiest thing I promise any
intercepts right let's go for the x and
y-intercepts right now for reasons that
will become very clear and second I'm
going to try and go for the y-intercepts
first so I'm going to say when x equals
0 ok this is to find a way visit right
so I go well this term disappears so I
get this equals 1 and as soon as you
write that you think oh ok this is why I
did it first right now River we're on
the Cartesian plane ok so what this
means is because i'm looking for values
that do this this means there are no
real solutions for wise now since there
are no real solutions for y what was I
trying to find it I was trying to find y
intercepts that means there aren't any
wine innocence and this corresponds
exactly to when you have a parabola
right and you go ahead and you try and
solve for y equal 0 and you don't get
solution we don't get a real one anyway
that's all it is positive was it
definite they can definitely whatever so
no y intercepts that's okay let's try
the other words let's let y equal zero
and see what happens then
this looks mercifully a little more
friendly right so your y squared term
disappears and then you say well I don't
how to solve that that's great okay so I
have some intercepts that's really
really good okay is there anything else
I can wait what would be the next
obvious step for like I've got a let's
let's draw a graph and completely and
let's start to add this information on
this we go
so plus or minus two that's nice
there's one of my innocence and
23
is my other interesting
okay so that's nice one man okay I'm
manager also included like I begin with
some geometric features did I not models
will include Vivian on my plantation
playing right I start off with a focus
and the directrix where are they over
here the focus is that are four comma 0
right so that's over yeah that's s4 come
0 and I got my directrix which is this
this vertical line in here executed
yes I'm so glad you mentioned all right